le site de sans souci est situé dans les
hauts de saint-paul en bordure du
rempart de la rivière des galets
l'exceptionnelle richesse floristique de
ce lieu se concentre au sein de trois
différents milieux forestiers
on situe dans un espace naturel très
particulier il ya ici on retrouve trois
étages de végétations c'est un des rares
endroits sur l'île on retrouve ces trois
étages de végétations c'est à dire de la
forêt semi sèche la forêt de bois de
couleurs des bye la forêt de bois de
couleur des eaux et 7
cette transition que les différents
étages on la retrouve quasiment nulle
part
le combat qu à son souci ici dans le
dans le coin il y à des espèces
remarquables de la forêt humide
d'altitude enfin de moyenne altitude
notamment on a retrouvé du bois blancs à
côté du bois de fer
il ya un grand appétit nadia sangwa
cassant tout toute une panoplie
en fait c'est un endroit relativement
riche par rapport à l'espace qui a et e
on retrouve et c'est un espace unique
parce que le l'écosystème n'est pas du
tout le même qu'on ne retrouve pas
ailleurs
l'action du conseil départemental
consiste à protéger à valoriser les
espaces naturels sensibles présentant un
intérêt écologique patrimonial ou
paysager la collectivité a donc confié
la gestion du site au groupement pour la
conservation de l'environnement et
l'insertion professionnelle de nombreux
sentiers sont entretenus et aménagé pour
permettre aux promeneurs de découvrir ce
site fatale entre par heure les fascine
pour sécuriser le sentier et puis
pouvoir protéger aussi de re l'érosion
parce que là on fait tous des roseaux
écouter ici et là entre préparer pour
bientôt
le grand raid au fait et comme il y aura
beaucoup deux coureurs pour faire
sécuriser le chantier ne paie pas les
vrais les goyaviers on va pas aller
piquer ton entre les piquets après
l'autre en lui bob bell et vous y avez
oranjes calais de la terre une partie du
site de son souci a été dédiée dès le
début du siècle à la culture du géranium
rosa originaires d'afrique il fut
introduit en 1870 sur l'île
les feuilles étaient principalement
utilisé pour la distillation des huiles
essentielles 75 hectares et ont été
cultivés il n'en reste aujourd'hui que
14 le site de sanssouci abrite encore
aujourd'hui plusieurs bus quand et leur
part celle ci c'est un bouc en dépit
dans les années 60 la saq fayard ou fait
le combiné puis la maintenance et là je
sais pas répond le boucan mais je
continuais plat des pieds l'enquêté le
boucan debout quand c'est pour quand ils
sortent d'en bal lundi dix mois l'été
calcia place jusqu'au vendredi après le
vent de vidéos et de sons durant tout le
mois d'octobre auront lieu les week-ends
nature mis en place par le conseil
départemental des visites guidées seront
alors proposés au public l'occasion pour
les amoureux de la nature de découvrir
ou redécouvrir ce site exceptionnel
alors découvrir aux jambes a justement
c'est les pratiques qu'ils avaient avant
sur ce site à l'époque où il était
cultivé au géranium
donc on pour on présentera aux jambes un
peu la vie qui avait autour de ces
boucan et puis comment se faisait les
plantations de géranium et les fuites de
géraniums on pourra malheureusement pas
faire une cuite mais
on expliquera quand même le principe de
la cuite et les gens pourront voir
comment ça se passe sur site
l'espace naturel sensible de sanssouci
présente un intérêt écologique mais
aussi une grande richesse à la fois
naturels et culturels